so if you haven't seen there are
activations that have come out against
david dobrik jason nash and kind of
uh the general group called the vlog
squad and so essentially those
uninitiated to the kind of youtube world
david dobrik
massive creator the people he has around
him the people he's brought up referred
to as the vlog squad and in recent weeks
several former members have gone on the
h3 podcast to air their concerns and
that's because we saw former member seth
francois coming out and saying that he
was assaulted during a prank that david
pulled on him with jason nash in 2017.
as far as what is being described as a
prank here you have david
asking seth would he be comfortable in a
video kissing karen a cop but
seemingly for this vlog is kind of the
joke reno would be wearing an old person
mask and a costume twitch seth says yes
he's new to the group he wants to help
david maybe also
he's open to kissing karina but instead
of sending out karina to kiss him david
puts out jason who was a 45 year old man
at the time they end up actually making
out for what feels like a while
what what what what what just happened
okay this youtuber would not be alive if
this he did this to [ __ ]
i'm sorry if i'm like yo you trying to
kiss this girl put on a blindfold
and i make you kiss a dude what you mean
okay so he put it oh my god am i lying
oh my god bruh i would never in my
entire life
think of doing that as a joke if i'm
doing that it's because i'm trying to
beef you
filming it [ __ ] are you putting it
online
it's a wrap it's a whole wrap it's a
delhi
it's dead you know what wow as a
straight person for you
and this is not an anti-thing i have my
orientation you
violated my boundaries yeah that's it
that's what it comes down to that's it
nah bro you gotta hold a big l for this
one that's
crazy that's crazy that's not a prank
that that's it's not a prank to violate
somebody's boundaries
do people not understand that you can't
just hit somebody and be like oh it's a
prank bro
it's why that other kid who ran up to
people he's like hey man
and he pulled out a knife and someone
shot him yeah he's like it's a prank bro
not a prank
that but but we knew that would happen
natural selection bro good for you
but good for you and i'm gonna say this
you know what i mean you played that
game with that kid but i tell you man
do that with the wrong person get
snuffed out listen i'm gonna say this
bro
maybe this is a hot take maybe this is
crazy
but i saw this whole platform come down
on shade dawson because of some comments
that he made about chunk was
unacceptable cool jada got online boom
bruh how is this kid allowed to do
pranks like this on this platform
basically
violating someone's boundaries to me
that's crazy how you can have those two
and think they're that separate
like this person talked about doing
[ __ ] up stuff and get them off i don't
care
fine what this is and you monetized it
and made money off of it but then we
have to cut certain words we have to
resort to using words like
womanism self delete right because we
don't
if we use the other word we're just
going to be demonetized right
but then you gonna mmm now bro
nah nah bro i don't think i'm
overreacting maybe i'm
i'm just saying if it's me in that
situation nah we're throwing hands
dennis where are your values that you
would violate someone's boundaries like
that for content that's what i don't
understand
also it appears that most viewers at the
time might have thought this was kind of
another scripted segment a fake thing
which is why we actually saw david
dobrik in the comments section saying
for the people saying this is fake are
you out of your mind jason nash in the
comments congratulating seth on what he
called his vlog initiation this is also
not the only time that seth got tricked
into kissing jason nash without his
consent deaths at around 2018 david kept
asking him what it would take to make
one of those videos again but seth kept
refusing saying he didn't like that
video that he didn't want to deal with
that situation again and so then
one day david asked seth to be in what
he thought was a beef jerky commercial
seth's excited think this is a huge
opportunity and on the set you had
people dressed like gorillas with seth
then told to make out with one of the
gorillas who
turned out to be jason nash even though
david knew seth wanted no part in it he
did it again and this
in part ultimately led to seth moving
out of los angeles with
also the jerky brand that was using that
fake ad having to come forward to
clarify that they were not in a
partnership with dobrik and they do not
condone what happened
bro i don't even know how to add
valuable commentary to this like
just play the goddamn thing nah bro you
did it once
twice even though he told you you know
what bro
my bad you were right there's some
people that are trash
you you guessed it you guessed it
there's some people that are trying you
know what bro that's something on
this day you was right there's some you
guessed it
you was right let's go man you know what
i should have value valued your opinion
last time
and recognize that it was low key noble
it was unacceptable me to just say no
because but you had a valid point i'm
gonna say this i'm gonna say
two things one for me this is not
necessarily about power this is about
the fact that somebody's
boundaries are violated thank you i
really believe this
if you'd flip these genders the response
would not be the same
of course because it's a man's
boundaries being violated this dude can
get on social media and keep posting
like nothing's happening
but you know i mean if you have a female
on the other side of that i'm not saying
like a female kid but
female kissing a 45 year old dude like
you get a lesbian to kiss another girl
she'd be down and then you make her kiss
a dude
you know what i mean i guess i just
don't understand
it's like i remember when when the whole
shane dawson stuff and he made those
comments about willow
right everyone went nuts and justifiably
so like i said i don't see how this is
not just as bad i think it's worse
i mean actions took place am i crazy for
saying this is this a hot take
no i feel like this is mild it's not a
hot day like it's a sub that's been on
the counter for an hour it's just
subway tara okay this is tara
so to me it just right there blew my
mind when i heard this story
just couldn't imagine doing something
like that to somebody with some creators
like nick kiswani otherwise known as big
nick saying that
the kind of the group was toxic it was
cult-like saying he was
involved forced to participate in jokes
making fun of his size and his expense
which
led to other people thinking they could
make fun of him for those reasons just
on that first topic
i think when you make your friends and
your family the content
sometimes you push the boundaries of
what they're comfortable with
to constantly extract things you
remember bad dad
no was that john it was like a dad
with a batman batman man oh yeah and it
was with his family
he was always nagging his his wife jen
yeah
and his kids and everything and stuff it
was fun at first but at some point you
know
growing kids you know your dad is always
going to bargain with a [ __ ] batman
and you know you don't have your privacy
you don't it was really fun but at some
point it's just like yo
bruv let me just chill let me just chill
i understand
it can become very old and at the point
like at some point we didn't they don't
last for years and years at some point
it's very tiring so at some point you
yeah and it also affects your
relationships to such a negative degree
so i was like are you really gonna
sacrifice the people around you for
content
yeah first off this person has no power
he's trying to appeal to you in your
group
and you violate his boundaries once in
such a terrible way i couldn't imagine
and then he said no i'm not okay with
this you were made aware and you double
down no it's not even the power thing
it is no it is no it is hold on hold on
it is hold on
he said no even if you're taking an
accountability the power thing
like you say that he had power he said
no
no i'm not doing one of those videos
therefore
he tricked him power or not
has nothing to do with power it does he
tricked him if i ask him to do a video
like that i'm gonna drink he's gonna say
no
i'm not gonna use my power i'm gonna use
him wanted to advance in a commercial
the only reason the only reason he wants
to be around him is because of the power
because him as who he was he stepped
forward
with all his power with who he was you
want to do one of those one of those
things again
and he said no so when he said no he
said no to the power
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna do it why do you trust them
i'm not saying no why'd he trust him
because it was something else
because i thought it was something else
no the reason why you're so willing to
trust someone like that the reason why
you're so willing to
give difference to that person's life is
because they have this image because
they have the squad because they can do
stuff
if he came to that dude and he's like yo
you're doing that and he said no
it's because he's saying all the power
because him if it was just for the power
if it was just for the power of me like
you know what he's powerful he's got
this and that
i'll do one of those sketches again he
would have done those sketches again
but now he said he decided to say no
and you had to trick him to change his
way look you know what it's not one of
those sketches
it's really just a commercial so we're
gonna put you in that commercial
so that's really what i think but i
understand what you're saying but i
don't agree
also i recognize that you maybe not seen
their videos before or seen what they
guys do
but they do these kind of pranks and
these kind of crazy stuff with all kinds
of people
all of these people are flocking towards
him because he has so much influence
and what ends up happening is that later
on they're like oh this person hurt me
oh this person well why were you there
because it's david dobrik in that same
token why would all those girls tolerate
what are kelly's doing
they can say all that stuff but his
power he's the
pied piper is he not i hate that term
but isn't that who he is though it's
like i get what you're saying because it
makes it worse the fact that he said no
he didn't know because he said actually
no to the power
right i agree but but here's here's the
the mind you think right
it's like preach if you know somebody's
dangerous
and they're dangerous and they come to
you and they're like hey man do you want
to do this
uh prank again and you're like no no and
then like would you want to do this
other thing
one of the few reasons that you would
trust that person even though there's
very little reason to trust that person
considering they violated your
boundaries
is because of who they are yeah right
like kelly comes to you and he says you
want to come in the shower you're like
no do you wanna come do this no
okay he's like well do you want to do
this water
why would you trust him knowing who he
is because of the image
yeah right right like that that buys you
a certain level of grace and a certain
level of like
i can do as much as i want in that same
token
a girl who's really attractive and who
has a hold on you can get away with a
lot
yeah because she's attractive yeah you
know so that's the part that bothers me
with this
i i get you wrong because actually your
point makes what he did
worse i agree on that no [ __ ] but the
power is always present in this
because the fact that he admired this
person yeah right
and in that case yeah yeah bobby
he says at the beginning i wanted to be
part i wanted to help out that's what he
says
and guys if you're watching this right
like you see us getting heated all this
stuff
we're not heated at each other no we're
heated about the situation
yes right because it's so stupid it's so
crazy
it actually i feel bad for the dude who
had that happened to him because he got
embarrassed
and he had his boundaries violated and
by millions of people for money
and he had his trust violated by people
he thought he could trust and who were
seemingly decent people you know so i
think that's why i'm heated sometimes it
doesn't always come out the right way so
we getting these
call that question no it's really just
we want you to know yeah it's really the
situation that gets
us like that we're just invested in
what's going on yeah it's not against me
and it's not against him yeah we're just
proving the point that's how we shoot
this
so don't be wild in the comments oh my
god
oh my god the disrespect
that he that's not that that ain't it no
don't be mad about [ __ ] that we ain't
even mad about what are your overall
thoughts on this whole thing
i got a couple of things well this is a
prank thing i was never a fan of the
prank things
the first minute that these things
happened on on youtube i was never
a prank thing and when some people would
send me
those prank things like yo for real
don't ever send me that
again i don't want to watch it i didn't
watch it
i don't want to engage in it you know
today we're going to go to the hood
and we're going to piss off some people
it's like taking advantage of the misery
of people i was never big on that
i was never watching it i was never down
with it you know what i mean